26 year old right-hander keegan thompson
will tell the slav for the cubs tonight
he'll come after these pirate hitters
with a four-pitch mix be aggressive
attack these pirate hitters that do not
have a lot of firepower in their lineup
and a swing and a miss
ahead 0-2 on gamble and then he's walked
him for reynolds
and he's going to be able to head on to
third
on that base hit by brian reynolds so
bucks on the pond with one out from
moran
and when hit to deep left and gone colin
moran goes the opposite way
a three run home run puts the bucks on
top here in the first mitch keller
making his 18th start
of the season for the pirates
bounced on the ground and that'll roll
through the left side that's a base hit
ortega just kind of touched it the other
way and it gets through oh my
look at that
and ortega
i mean it was kind of a one one thousand
two one thousand
that he took off for second but it'll be
that's an error on everybody
lined to the center field and hat
with a base hit ortega will stop at
third
that's a nice pitch by keller to get
wisdom
swing and a miss he blew it by him at 96
on the outer edge that's what we're
talking about iris batting here in the
second leading three nothing
and a base hit
keller will tiptoe to third
and brian reynolds with a multi-hit game
by the second inning and that's going to
do it for keegan keegan thompson
frustrating night
and he strikes him out third strikeout
for mitch keller
and keller with four strikeouts
through two innings
here's a bouncer to short fielded by
alcantara quick throw to first in time
to get the fleet-footed alfred one two
three for samson nicely done
mitch keller really the story tonight he
has pitched very well against his cubs
nine he has struck out five
look at this nice play there's the arm
throws him out
everybody's rising and applauding this
one
[Music]
beautiful
and gets a guy who can really run and
cole tucker nice play
[Applause]
here's the 3-2 in a bouncing ball to the
shortstop tucker he scoops
and throws and gets
patrick wisdom and nice work for keller
[Music]
and a high fly ball to shallow left
center field coming in as reynolds and
the left fielder alford calls off
reynolds and tucker who went out and
good work once again by mitch keller
through four innings
nice pitch right there
adrian sampson locked in he's retired
all ten men that he's faced were midway
in the fifth three nothing pirates
on the ground
and tucker picks it up and the throw
pulls moran off the base and sergio is
safe
and killer picks apart the pinch hitter
how about mitch keller seven strikeouts
tonight working around that lead off and
he has been on tonight
swinging to miss zephros gets stallings
the 2-2 swung on and missed strike three
one two three inning for scott f ross
mitch keller pitching great only runner
past first base tonight for the cubs was
ortega the leadoff man in the first
inning
this ball is bounced to first moran
tosses to keller covering that's a big
first down here in the sixth inning
and he strikes him out now don't want to
do that too often putting it in that
spot but that shows you sometimes when
he got good stuff it works
duffy another hit that's into center
and with two outs of knock
here's the 02.
the fly ball to center reynolds is back
a few steps he's got room he'll make the
catch
mitch keller
for the third time and his career goes
six innings
and this was a dandy
[Applause]
and frost gets some swinging scott afros
has come on the pirates don't have a
base runner or a hit since the second
inning 3-2
swing and a miss struck him out cubs
bullpen has been sensational
veteran right-hander chad cool
roller along third
charging evans throw safe at first and
chirinos beats it out
that one ripped fair ball into the right
field corner
chasing after it is gamma torinos
will stop at third alcantara
is into second
torino's at third alcantara at second
club's trying to get on the board here
drill
that one in the air right field gamble
back near the wall out of here
and we
are tied
ortega unloads
3-3
and ian happ coming up and now you've
got schwendel at first
drilled in the air high and deep right
field gavel at the wall god
stay hot in half
and it is 5-3
393 feet nothing but singles until the
seventh but the cubs unload here double
and a couple of home runs
on the ground schwendel
they go to second for one morgan gets
there
and stumbles but gets the bag and it's a
double play
[Applause]
and stratton
strikes out three in the inning well up
to the bucks bats now they need a pair
to keep it going stallings will lead it
off and it's first and second
oh barely staying alive oh i thought
that maybe catchers interference it was
it was called yes that loads the bases
that's big well that lights something in
the pirate offense
and he ropes it into right here comes
stallings default behind him and perez
ties the game with the pitch hit single
in the knife
little bouncer
tucker throws out duffy and he'll grab a
helmet and take second base we're gonna
go to extra innings and now the go ahead
run into scoring position
and roll to first windell comes home and
they tag him out
[Applause]
on the ground
alcantara handles fires to duffy and
they get out of it that was hit hard
chirinos one out of four trying to be a
hero
big strikeout by bednar
he struck him out
bednar blew it by him for the bucks to
have a chance of the 11th infield in hat
with an opportunity to win it runner
goes this one popped up
[Applause]
right side defoe scrambling
oh and it falls
racing home is alcatra and the cubs win
holy cow